ein thema das uns gestern schon
beschäftigt hat das war das foto der
spd-bundestagsfraktion ein gruppenfoto
und wir sehen nur einen mann der sich
dort an die masken pflicht gehalten hat
das ist unser gas karl lauterbach alle
anderen haben keine maske an mich kriegt
gar nicht auf dass dort die politiker
ohne maske stehen mich regt auf dass die
masken pflicht noch nicht insgesamt
abgeschafft wurde dass in schulen
weiterhin masken getragen werden müssen
dort aber die politikerinnen und
politiker sich ohne maske zeigen das
nenne ich doppelmoral
naja das war jetzt nur ein ganz kurzer
moment muss man sagen und die fraktionen
ist geimpft und getestet von daher
bestand kein risiko aber es ist schon
richtig dass wir uns in den innenräumen
des bundestages nur mit maske bewegen
müssen die frage ist ja brauchen wir die
maske noch in den schulen das hat die
eigentlich also entscheidende frage das
war hier ein moment wo man vielleicht so
oder so hätte entscheiden können alles
gut was ging da den leuten durch den
kopfball war ganz schwierig aber ich
werde mich nicht über die leute die dort
aber sie haben ja maske getragen ja ja
das hat er offen gesagt also die maske
routinemäßig getragen weil ich also im
bundestag hat immer die maske tragen
weil das die jungs vorschrift ist aber
man kann natürlich in so einem moment wo
ein foto gemacht wird kann man aus
meiner sicht die maske auch abnehmen das
ist ganz klar von daher halte ich nicht
für problematisch die kolleginnen und
die kollegen haben nichts falsch gemacht
was will ich festhalten dass ich gegen
die vorschriften verstoßen da war sich
dann sind die vorstellungen für ein foto
kann man etwas abnehmen dass es aus
meiner sicht alles gut aber die viel
interessantere frage ist ja was machen
in den schulen und es gibt tatsächlich
also zum einen klare studien die zeigen
dass also die masken in den schulen
etwas bringen das ist durch
wissenschaftlich ist das belebt aber es
gibt auch eine möglichkeit die masken
pflicht auszusetzen den schulen da muss
man aber sehr strengen eine alternative
fahren und diese alternative ist wie
folgt wenn man die kinder vor der schule
also vor dem beginn der schule dreimal
pro woche testet und für den fall dass
ein kind dann positiv ist mit alle
kinder in der klasse fünf tage
hintereinander jeden tag morgen testet
dann kann man mathematisch zeigen dass
also
großen ausbrüchen in der schule nicht
mehr kommt also das wäre sozusagen sehr
kompliziert ich habe es nicht einmal zu
kommen und zurückkommen zu der szene
weil das interessiert mich jetzt auch
jetzt steht da karl lauterbach tja wie
ist man einer der großen corona experten
der republik neben sich weil sie ja
wieviel 210 92 106 206 kollegen die alle
keine maß gaben jetzt sieht karl aut
aber weiterhin auch eine sieht karl
lauterbach aber doch all die fragen die
maske jetzt nicht obwohl sie es
eigentlich müssten
haben sie da was gesagt oder oder oder
doch das sind noch in diskussion ob ich
damals gesagt habe und so kommt einfach
mal sagen und
nicht beim ausschank oder
nein aber also ich habe ja eben schon
gesagt die kolleginnen und kollegen
haben nichts falsch gemacht das war ein
moment hat wo ein bild gemacht wurde da
ist niemand gefällt gewesen weil die
heiß sind alle games oder getestet wie
oft mit der fertig soll ich mal tolles
zeichen was damit gesetzt wird die
politiker die wasser predigen und wein
trinken oder gewundert und mögen ja es
hat doch nichts damit zu tun es hat doch
mit der außenwirkung zu tun die ganze
fraktion steht da ohne maske unsere
kinder müssen in der schule sitzen und
müssen diese verdammte ganzen
unterschiede gehören es geht mir gar
nicht um den unterschied es gibt nur
auswirkungen und ich finde ich finde
dass politiker sich auch über ihre
außenwirkung bewusst sein müssen und da
auch vorbild als vorbild vorangehen aber
man kann es auch so sehen wenn wir zum
beispiel im bundestag ein interview
geben dann tragen wir auch keine maske
dass da noch nicht vorgesehen weil
einfach nicht mehr gerade das aber auch
ein abstand zu wahren genau und er war
es jetzt ein fototermin und da kann man
unterschiedlicher meinung sagen ich habe
hier die maske getragen von daher machen
aber die anderen haben auch nichts
falsch gemacht aber ich glaube das ist
also
wichtig ist dass wir über die dinge
sprechen die jetzt anstehen und was
jetzt ansteht ist tatsächlich die frage
was er jetzt in jedem bundesland anders
entschieden wird müssen die kinder noch
die maske tragen ja oder nein von daher
ist es lohnt es sich darüber
nachzudenken und ich mache einen
vorschlag an dem sind noch nicht so oft
gehört wurde es geht ohne maske wenn man
es nach dem system macht drei mal testen
pro woche morgens und ist ein kind
positiv dann also die anderen kinder
fünf tage hintereinander testen dann
könnten die meisten wahrscheinlich nicht
also könnte man wahrscheinlich auf die
masken verzichten denn das fragen sich
ja das hat das andere lösen beunruhigt
weil sich nicht schick so zurück
da viel offensiver unterwegs ich habe
mir vorgenommen heute erst mal zuzuhören
und wie heißen die argumentation
anzuhören und dann nicht einzuschalten
ich höre hier sehr rege zu wie ist deine
meinung was man in den schulen angeht
maske insgesamt eigentlich bist du eine
klare verfechterin und sagst was dann
sofort gestern hast du mich sogar noch
anarchisten genannt ist habe ich sogar
in der sache als kompliment wahrgenommen
paul meine meinung habe ich ja gestern
schon zum ausdruck gebracht ich finde ja
auch dass sich eigentlich alle auf dem
bild richtig feiert am außer sehr lauter
warten hier möchte ich aber noch mal in
der sendung sagen ich bin gestern etwas
übers ziel hinaus geschossen dafür
möchte ich mich entschuldigen ich hätte
nicht sagen dürfen dass sie dir haben
will man der woche sind einfach weil
meinungsfreiheit ist wichtig wir stehen
hier dafür ein das möchte ich mich
entschuldigen und eine meinung bleibt
aber dieselbe der sich finde ich sehe
das auch anders als ein nettes war das
richtige signal dass sie keine maske
anhalten wir haben auch mit blick auf
die aktuellen zahlen ich finde auch bei
schul fotos jan fleischhauers er mich
wirklich bestürzt hat heute getwittert
von so einem foto kann sein sohn nur
träumen der eltern eingeschult wird vom
klassenfoto wo alle keine masken haben
da habe ich gedacht ja aber das sollen
die doch auch machen also wir können
auch jetzt nicht sagen toll dass alle da
wie schlimm dass alle keine maske auf
hatten wegen der außenwirkung alle waren
genesen oder geimpft richtig genießen
oder gesetzt haben jetzt alle user
interessant haben sich alle wissen sie
dass alle in der spd fraktion geimpft
sind ist es das ist mein 100 prozent
quote also mein kenntnisstand ist auf
jeden fall dass alle genesen geimpft
oder getestet sind genau wie das ist
doch total affig sich da mit einer maske
hinter ihr steht ich geb dir ja total
recht aber es kann nicht sein dass es
von anderen verlangt wird und hier muss
man es nicht machen mir geht es nur um
die außenwirkung und was bei den
menschen da draußen ankommt nämlich die
politiker erzählen uns was anderes als
das was sie selber machen und das
funktioniert für mich nicht ich finde
auch ich habe auch keine lust mehr auf
die masse und mir wäre es auch lieber
wir könnten sie heute ablegen und nicht
erst morgen aber ich finde es ist ganz
wichtig um eben auch authentisch zu sein
und wir wundern uns warum die leute
irgendwie sagen eure politik ist mist
und daher den kann man sowieso nichts
abnehmen wenn sie sich dann so
darstellen ja das ist schon also ist es
schon ein unterschied ob ich meine
deswegen ist bei den kindern zu bleiben
wo ich ja gerade einen vorschlag gemacht
habe wie es einmal testen dann in moskau
drama testen und über ist das
realistisch sehen wir ja gar nicht hier
der entscheidende punkt ist wirklich
dass man also wenn ein kind positiv ist
alle kinder die also in der klasse noch
sind fünf tage lang hintereinander
testet weil das wird überall wird an
vielen stellen schon drei mal gebraucht
man den erwachsenen jesus gemacht
natürlich würde wenn ich das bei den
erwachsenen was unterscheidet ihr
meinetwegen die erwachsenen die in ein
restaurant gehen und die kinder also die
man deswegen in der schule sind naja bei
den erwachsenen ist es so dass jetzt die
meisten geimpft sind und bei den kindern
sind es 30 bis 60 prozent dass ihr
unterschied und selbst also wenn ich
hier sind ein restaurant gehe wann bist
du zuletzt in einem restaurant gewesen
hast du sechs stunden gesessen dann also
das kommt nicht so
musste man muss die dinge dann also
schon also sagen wir realistisch
miteinander vergleichen daher kann man
so ein foto auch nicht nur der
schulkasse vergleichen weil ich gebe
mein ehrenwort wir haben nicht sechs
stunden dafür verwendet dieses bild zu
machen das ging viel schneller und das
löst sich dann auf somit also wir
brauchen ein klassenfoto darauf baut
auch braucht ja auch keine sechs stunden
wenn jetzt in klassen foto gemacht wurde
ohne maske da hätte ich wenn das draußen
wäre beispielsweise hätte ich ja und
null probleme mit ihr wäre ich der
letzte wäre ich der letzte das man muss
ja auch sagen mal die regeln also mit
verstand machen also wenn jetzt raus
aber da haben die deutschen endlich mal
das gefühl dass die regel mit verstand
gemacht wenn er lauter aber auch wenn
man hat das gefühl dass corona keine
große gefahr mehr ist mittlerweile man
hat das gefühl dass andere längst ein
freedom day machen wie in großbritannien
das große thema und wir weiter über
masten vielleicht reden wir uns fragen
wie lange müssen wir noch mit diesem
ding rumlaufen will auch jetzt
anderthalb jahren wir sind entweder sind
diejenigen getestet die sind geimpft
oder sie sind heute genießen und wer
sich nicht testen lassen will oder
impfen lassen für die braucht man
regelung aber ist nicht mal der moment
gekommen wo man sagt ja dass die
regelung und blick auf die zahlen weder
das sehe ich komplett anders
[Musik]